Okay so
we already talked about system calls.
In fact,
I said think about the cost of a system
call compared to a regular call.
So system calls allow you to go from
user mode to OS or the system mode.
So let's talk a little bit
more about system calls.
First of all, they're used to transfer
control between user and system code.
Or execution that must happen
in user mode and system mode.
The interesting thing about these calls
is that they cannot be arbitrary.
These are a set of calls that user
level code is allowed to make.
Okay, this is defined by the application
programming interface, or
the API that your
operating system provides.
So, you have these calls, and
these calls have to come into
the operating system in
a control fashion, okay.
So we said these calls
are different than regular calls.
They have to come through what
used to be called call gates,
which is special ways in which
you can enter from user to,
it's a defined way,
transition from user to system level.
You come through these call gates.
And what happens as a result of that is,
well we know that it's a call,
so we going to return at some point.
So we have to keep track of
where we going to return and
the user code once
the system call completes.
But the processor execution mode
has to change as a result of that.
We went from user mode to system mode so
the privilege ring or
the mode is going to change.
And we actually going to be able to,
we'll have to change some memory
mappings, data structures that keep
track of those, because we going to
be able to access memory now
that we couldn't access before.
So some registers have to be saved.
Others have to be loaded.
And things like that.
So all that work has to be done.
So now we are executing in
a different protection domain.
In fact, this used to happen through,
sort of an interrupt or
a trap into the system from user mode.
But in x86,
we actually have explicit instructions.
This is different from
your regular call return.
These are execute a system call.
That Sysenter enter the system or
the operating system and
when you're done you return by doing
another special instruction called
sysexit so there are these instruction
that help you implement this system
calls that we're talking about.
Keep in mind that they are more
expensive because now we're using,
we're doing this work
that we didn't have to.
We have to check what kind of call it
is, arguments that are being passed.
Same information when we come back.
We change memory mapping so we can
access things that we couldn't before,
use the special instructions rather
than the regular ones and so on.
So that's what makes it costlier or
more expensive.